what kind of man will come north of
savoia
by the lock I had a bush pilot fritz
Meyer who I don't think he'd ever done
aerial photography before but he was so
good that if I'd never been there he
would have done wonderful aerial
photography the camera was mounted right
in the nose of the plane so if anything
the audience in the IMAX theater has an
experience more intense and the pilot
does because the pilots sitting back in
a cockpit looking through a window and
the camera was just out there having the
point of view of the airplane itself and
so the audience is having the experience
but flight unmediated by any other
intervening factors
I've worked with a lot of pilots and
they're something that just just don't
get it they don't understand how to
maneuver the plane to make a good shot
and it was just natural to quit
he flew very low over a number of places
and he was quite surprised when this
flight was over he looked at his wing
and there stuck in the end of the wing
was a pine cone that indicated that we'd
flown about as low as we could